two few teachers are getting the
training and support they need to teach
about the Holocaust and that's according
to MPs in a report that also recommends
testimonies of survivors should be used
as essential teaching material Charlotte
low mass reports Viki shipper arrived
ash for its Birkenau in 1944 aged as
fourteen years old
separated from his grandmother he
watched as Nazi girls decided who was
fit for work and who instead would be
killed German SS cars were pointing
right left right left and we were just
standing there waiting or sitting on the
ground you know and eventually we sold
that and most of the people that went to
the right or left whatever it was the
oak people disabled people children
babies and women holding babies so
determined gods came over and asked the
women to put the baby down and go to the
other side well you can you imagine a
mother doing it sure dirt that had to
rip that baby out of their house rather
than forget the horrors he went through
Ziggy spends his days talking about his
experience at schools all over the
country it's personal testimonies like
his and other Holocaust survivors which
the Education Committee say are vital in
teaching students about the Holocaust
they claim history teachers however need
better training so to change this the
Education Committee are calling on the
government to improve training for
teachers and extend the teaching of the
Holocaust to other subjects such as
English and drama when I heard a
survivor speak I thought I'm not doing
this properly
I have a responsibility I have a duty to
do it properly and that is when I
started to look around for training and
that's where I found great training at
places like the center for Holocaust
education which has enabled me probably
to teach my most impactful lessons of
the year there's little disagreement
that learning about the Holocaust is an
important part of Education these sixth
formers also believe is encourage them
to study other
at ease in modern history the Holocaust
is probably the best example from
history but it's not enough to say that
the Holocaust is the only genocide
that's ever happened because we're under
Darfur Cambodia it's been great to learn
about those ones as well for most people
the Holocaust is textbook history but
for the remaining few it's the living
memory on Ziggy wants to make sure is
shared for years to come
Charlotte Lomas Sky News